what is up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio fantastic Fest
2023 I am with the filmmaker behind what
is one of my favorite films of the
festival so far JT molner for strange
darling congratulations this one is
really something else oh thank you so
much so the first thing I need you to do
because I know about your movie I love
your movie A lot of people here love
your movie our audience has not heard of
strange darling yet so can you give
everyone a brief synopsis one day in the
Romantic Twisted love life of a serial
killer that's it usually I ask people to
give a synopsis so our audience can be
informed but also I know where to stop
for spoilers this is a very difficult
movie to talk about and like to convey
how damn good it is without giving away
certain details and I find it so
frustrating thank you for that
um for me you know I go see movies and I
always hope that um I'm gonna be
surprised or it's going to take me in a
direction I'm I always want my
expectations subverted and so often
they're not uh and so when I when I as
making a movie I'm trying to just you
know do something that I'd enjoy myself
and so the the goal was definitely to to
go in interesting different directions
and so I'm glad we surprised you a
little bit very much so and I'll just
I'll emphasize this uh interview is
totally spoiler free you are safe here
but try to go into this movie knowing as
little as possible because it is
exceptional and you do some uh really
unique uh storytelling work here and we
will get into the non-linear structure
at the very least but before I get there
I did want to ask you about going from
first to second feature two-part
question on that what would you say is
one of the biggest misconceptions about
getting a green light on your second
film after making your first but then
also what is something about the
reception to your first that helped you
get this movie off the ground and the
way you wanted it's interesting
um I uh you know the fir my first movie
went to Sundance and it was uh my guess
now oh it's rough I think it was seven
years ago which with the pandemic and
the shutdown and everything at time got
weird for all of us so um it feels more
like four years to me but it's it's been
a while and I remember it took me about
10 years of making short films and doing
things to finally uh to finally get a
feature greenlit my first feature was
never supposed to be a very commercial
movie and we made it for very little
money and uh we're really grateful that
the people at Sundance wanted to play it
there and of course when it got released
and got sold I thought um I would just
be doing that every year I mean not
necessarily every year but maybe every
two years develop and then make a movie
and um the movie came out and it it
opened all kinds of doors for me I mean
I was able to stop bartending and I was
able to make a modest living as as a as
a director and a writer doing things
um but I started you know developing my
second feature and um we'd have cast and
no money money and no cast and um and
the reviews were very mixed on my first
movie and it wasn't a massive hit or
anything like that so it opened all
kinds of doors and allowed me to
um be taken seriously a little bit uh
but it the second movie seemed much
harder to make than the first one it was
bizarre and um and I wrote
uh I'm not talking about writing now but
I wrote back then I wrote a bunch of
scripts and I I uh that I wanted to
develop and um and it was just really
weird because I kept running into uh
brick walls and or we'd we'd developed
something and then it would fall apart
for one reason or another
um this film was really weird because
um I had this uh this thing ready to go
and
um we took it
around and then all of a sudden four
months later we were shooting it was
like the quickest it was weird because
it was very very difficult to get
something made but once I decided to
make this it was the quickest easiest
development it was it was something that
never happens it was like a dream come
true I went in and sat down with with
Bill block and Miramax and in the
meeting he said let's make the movie so
um it was it was bizarre it was like
surreal now once we made the movie it
was
the very very it was a very difficult
crazy you know like everybody making a
movie it was very uh trying experience
but
um but the process of getting it made
once I decided to make this one was
quick it was one of those weird things
revisiting many scenes of this movie I
can understand why the production
process would be quite challenging yeah
I wanted to go back to the the
non-linear story idea and again we're
not going to spoil anything about it but
I am curious is it more or less
challenging to pitch a non-linear story
to financiers and producers because this
is an industry where you know someone
might hear oh this starts at chapter uh
I believe chapter three like that's
weird that's never gonna work I'm not
even gonna read the rest of it and
understand why it's structured that way
so it doesn't make it more or less
challenging it's interesting because I
think this movie to me would be
um boring if it were in order so
personally uh it's just me uh but I or
just simplistic right like it would it
would be conventional I think and so uh
it came to me in it was always supposed
to be in this order and um the story it
plays that way
um for a reason and out of that order it
just wouldn't make sense so it was it it
seems like it would be a hard thing to
pitch but I in this case it wasn't
because people understood that
um it was weird because after I finished
shooting it uh was when there were
certain people I mean it was mixed
feeling I mean I didn't have uh Final
Cut on the movie or or but it ended up
being my cut I mean a very this is we we
reached an agreement and this is the cut
that I wanted and I'm very happy with it
but
um there was a time when the director's
cut was first submitted where there was
kind of a mixed uh some people who had
influence over the movie wanted it to
maybe be in sequence and some people
didn't and
um I nobody really knows when we're in
this vacuum watching you know it's 10 of
us or something looking at a movie and
I'm really close to two at that period
so it's like is this
um should it be in sequence but I always
felt that it couldn't be and so we we
ended up all coming to a consensus that
we were going to keep it out of sequence
thankfully and and now that's the
version you saw usually I'm very
open-minded about hearing other opinions
about things but like no in this
particular case that was the right and
only answer to that I have to talk about
your cast here because I'm sure you go
into it with a great script but I do
think the success of a of a concept like
this hinges on finding the Perfect Two
performers and you very much do with
Willa and Kyle so when you first met
them can you tell me something about
each of them that made you think you are
going to crush this role but also you
are going to be a good creative partner
for me oh yeah it you know um one of the
great things that happened on this movie
for me is that Miramax actually
um there was a period where we were kind
of uh talking about a little bit of like
value and names and who is going to but
it was very quick and they actually
um at miramex they they told me at some
point like we want you to hire people in
these leads who are um accomplished and
who are known and who have done things
but um don't worry about the level of
star power or this or that like don't
worry about just cast who's right and
I've never had a financier do that
before and even though I've only made
two movies I've worked with many
financiers and you know movies have been
developed but this was great because I
kind of um was able to really meet with
people uh who I thought were right for
it and of course the studio had to
approve but they were very supportive
um and I there's a there's an agent
named Christy Hall and agents get a real
bad rap but Chrissy Hall's an agent at
Paradigm and she's one of my uh favorite
people in the world and she
um uh I called her up and said I have
this role and I have some people in mind
uh who do you think and she started
pitching Willa and and Kyle both of them
right off the bat and so I wanted to
cast the protagonist I want to cast the
lady first
um and build around her and we we didn't
even care about uh age range it was sort
of like I just wanted a vulnerability in
a Charisma and and you know something
that you had to look at and and just a
really great actor to be in that role
and we had my wish list was had people
who were 50 and people who were 20. I
mean it was just a big range and we
figured we'd cast
um the uh the the villain against that
right so
um I met with Willa and she was actually
a little younger than I initially uh
thought would be right for it
um but we had this amazing meeting and
uh and the same thing happened with with
Kyle
um and one thing I loved about both of
them is that uh and this is what I was
really looking for I mean I saw their
work
um I watched dinner in America and I
watched all the reacher episodes
so good right and um and it was weird I
I was a big fan of The Goldfinch
um and Willa doesn't have a huge role in
that movie but she's one of the people I
remember the most from the movie and
it's so different than this role but I
knew she had that quality right so and I
could see her range it kind of
disappeared into different characters
and um and so for me it was when I met
her it was about how she gonna work how
she see this character how does he see
this character around I met with him and
both of them the reason I fell in love
with them as actors is because they
started talking to me about
um they had so much compassion for their
characters and uh I had some other
meetings where people didn't have
compassion for the characters and so
when I talked to both of these people
all they spoke about was what they
related to in in these characters and um
and how they could see their character's
point of view and that's what I wanted I
wanted them to really uh love who they
were playing for all their faults right
and and that's why I think to me
um there there's just a lot of humanity
uh in the roles and it's not because of
um how how the roles were written it's
because of the actors and so I'm just so
proud of both of them and so grateful
that they uh wanted to do this
um with me and and I think you know uh
just I I mean I I was when I watch them
I had dinner with dinner with Willa a
little while ago
um and I was looking at her across the
table and I said I just she didn't
change her appearance that much but I
just said I you're totally you're not
the lady like you're Willa and
um when somebody can do that it's just
remarkable uh and I love actors because
I was an actor for a little while early
on I always wanted to be behind the
camera but uh because I've I've tried it
and I've done it I know how difficult it
is so um yeah I'm just blown away by
both of them and I think the movie
wouldn't work uh if they hadn't been
cast properly you could totally tell
that this is a movie made by a director
who loves and respects the craft of
acting and I really appreciate that to
build on that a little more can you
maybe tell tell me something about each
of their approaches to the work that
calls for something different from you
as an actor's director in order to you
know give them the best working
environment and bring the best out of
them as actors yet for me I've realized
that uh I think being a director for me
is about
um finding the language uh the proper
language to communicate with each actor
so every actor that I've worked with has
a different language and um sometimes
you're feeling that out over the course
of the first few days and the language
for Kyle was much different than the
language for Willa and um I think a
ineffective director probably wouldn't
pay attention to
um that language like this is how I say
things this is how I want you to do
things and you're going to do it but one
thing I'm fascinated by is finding out
I'm really interested in is finding out
what makes them tick uh what will help
them uh reach their best level and so
will is an excellent Communicator uh we
we'd never worked with each other and we
spent the first two days trying to
figure it out and um and we had a talk
after a couple days and she explained to
me what helps her best and and what she
needs to know about her character in
order to perform at her highest level
and so I made sure I facilitated that at
all times for her and then Kyle um was
like this is how I like it and this is
what I do you know it's it's uh it's
like a dance and um and both of them
take their job so seriously and care so
much much that it really helps you don't
have to do much as a director when the
actors care so much about their
performance that they're protecting it
at all times too uh you know Willa many
times would
um I thought you know I thought I had
what I needed and I did have what I
needed it would have worked but she'd be
like you know
can we get one more because I'd like to
try it this way and she maybe did that
three or four times over the shoot and I
think every one of the times she did
that I used that take so so she knew
best really
um and uh and then of course we had you
know Barbara Hershey and Ed Begley Jr on
set mentoring all of us and they were
just amazing but um but I'm just I want
to work with these two actors over and
over and over again I hope I get lots of
opportunities I do not blame you one bit
I have so many other elements of this
production I need to touch on one thing
I wanted to ask you about was was the
Wardrobe for both characters one because
Kyle's character is basically wearing
the same thing the entire time and it
needs to speak to who he is and maybe
his past a little and then with Willa's
character there are so many I mean I'll
go as far to say this there's so many
iconic looks that had character rocks in
this film so maybe what was the approach
to finding the right thing for Kyle and
of all of Willa's looks which one went
through the biggest Evolution as you
spoke with your uh costume designer
about it it's weird I have this I think
it's a sub conscious thing like when I'm
directing a movie and thinking of things
and colors and doing things like I I
don't
um I'm not usually consciously trying to
make a statement or do a certain thing
but then later I'll watch and and I'll
know where something came from right and
so uh it's interesting I I I was
thinking as we were watching the movie
last night that um in my first film
there's a transformation
um that uh the lead character makes and
um it's sort of this I was watching the
movie last night and I was like I think
I like this weird like the superhero
concept where you know people have
um uh they can transform they can it's
Chrysalis type thing and that uh I had
all these different ideas of
um uh different versions of uh Willa's
character I wanted to see and a couple
different versions of Kyle's that I
wanted to see and um but I also knew how
we wanted to make the audience feel
um through the whole movie and so more
than anything else I thought color would
be the best way to make the audience
feel
um and so I enlisted uh Priscilla
Elliott who's one of the greatest
production designers the greatest
production designer in the world and um
and I begged her to do the movie and she
I got referenced her by uh friend
Richard Kelly who directed Donnie Darko
and he braved about her and I brought
her on and then Rudy Rojas was the
costume designer and we worked really
closely together because we talked about
color control
um and how we wanted to stick with
certain color palette for everything for
the entire movie and um and every
everything you see on the lady
everything you see on the demon
um were things that we had extensive
discussions about you know for uh the
entire you know eight weeks of prep or
whatever and um and I I really I wanted
to I mean you never know how many people
are going to see your movie uh maybe 10
people will see this movie but I I
remember talking to Willow I think
you've already surpassed yeah
I don't know but I I think I remember
talking to Willow and being like I just
want people to dress up like you for
help yes
things that I thought From the Moment
the movie opened and then you keep
delivering more options and I don't know
I like I want everyone to see it ASAP so
I could see some this year but I'll take
some costumes next year too
yeah yeah we we got really we had a lot
of fun with uh with uh especially her
clothing I thought it was just uh I
don't know like it we just everything we
were like well that would be cool to put
those you know everything was just a lot
of fun and
um we knew how the demon
we really wanted Kyle to look
a certain way and um and just be a
fierce presence
um and a very intimidating presence
um and uh I think we even you know his
who are some glasses and they were kind
of uh what I saw some old pictures
Jeffrey Dahmer was wearing glasses like
that
um but we we wanted them also to have
um because we're talking a lot about you
know good and evil and how they're
really you know there's all this area
this gray area in between and and
um so we wanted also some of their
colors to match because uh we didn't
want
um such a clear-cut divide I mean you
know somebody might be a killer and
somebody might not be but it doesn't
mean they're not flawed it also doesn't
mean if they're a killer they don't have
um uh some compassion within them uh you
know anyway any more questions I I need
to I need to let you go soon but I
wanted to follow up on something because
over the course of this conversation I
get the sense that you're a filmmaker
with a great attention to detail can you
maybe give us an example of something in
this movie that I guess might seem small
to like folks out there watching the
film they would think like oh that's
just something you like whipped up and
it like worked out in the movie but it
was something that required one of those
really like lengthy deep conversations
in order to find the pitch perfect way
to bring that to life on screen you know
let's let's say uh there's a there's a
scene
um where the lady's escaping into the
woods and uh she ends up coming Upon A
she ends up coming upon a cottage
um and uh
if you noticed there's a lot of flowers
and colors
um
there's flowers everywhere all outside
of the the cottage and um Reds Blues
yellows primary colors and um we wanted
to Priscilla and I the first thing we
talked about was blood on the flower bed
like that's what the we wanted the movie
to have a candy coating my first movie
desaturated it it was like McCabe and
Mrs Miller we wanted it Grant we wanted
you know it washed out this movie was a
different a different approach we looked
at movies like dead ringers we looked at
Blue Velvet you know we looked and we
really wanted it to have that sort of
candy coating and so we wanted that to
the dichotomy
um between the the violence and the the
colors and the richness we wanted to
feel kind of like a fairy tale right and
so um
all the flowers uh as as she's
approaching the house everything was put
there uh by the art Department I mean
they brought in truckloads of flowers so
that's something every time I see it I'm
really proud of of Priscilla and her
whole department for doing that and
that's that's just one of the many
things um that we did to and there's
also I don't know if you noticed the the
framed uh painting of of uh Ed Begley Jr
and Barbara Hershey yeah yeah so there's
there's that too so it just those are
fun things for me everything
um
capsule or something right now but I'm
hoping miramex lets me have it I really
I wouldn't blame you I'd want to keep
that thing
um the last thing I'll ask you about is
is on your shirt the uh the choice to uh
film this in 35 to get at that from two
angles why why do many filmmakers often
Veer towards digital what are some of
the challenges one must face when they
want to shoot on on film but then also
what was it about shooting on film that
you thought would best enhance this
story on screen
um well it's I mean for me it's never
been a choice
um I I started shooting short films when
digital was at its peak of kind of you
know 2009 2010 2011 everybody who was
doing short films or or low budget films
were shooting digitally a lot of people
um we went to Sundance with my first
movie we shot on film and I think the
only other film there that year was on
film was Kelly reichardt's movie uh and
now I think last year there were like 20
movies so it's had this great Resurgence
in large part because of um Steve
Bellamy and Vanessa medetti who who uh
Steve's the president of Kodak and she
runs it with him and um I just
believe so much that you know
moving pictures
um light through images it's so powerful
and it it also um not only is the
texture and the look of it just
unsurpassed by by any camera and I know
there's really good digital cameras out
there but there's a feeling you get from
film that that you you can't you can't
match and also there's something on set
that happens when you're shooting film
um
the the whole level of of approach the
the cast The Crew I mean I grew up
reading books about you know uh Sam Peck
and Paul's process and bergman's process
and you're watching you know uh you're
watching the reverence uh these sets the
reverence around the process and so for
me every short film I did except for one
and it was for a very specific reason
was shot on film and both my features
were shot on film and maybe I would have
made a few more movies
um but I I've always said I'd rather
direct uh plays than than shoot uh not
on film so I hope I can stick to that
but this movie had to be as you notice
there's um I think you probably noticed
there it's it's a it takes place in
modern times but it was influenced by
um movies from a different time and so
uh we knew in order to find that
aesthetic the only way to go was was 35
millimeter and that's how um Giovanni
Ribisi and I um bonded over film stock
and he he's a cinematographer and uh we
just loved film in the process and so it
was never it was never a choice and
everybody would pitch this movie too I
would just say listen I know I haven't
made a movie in a few years I know maybe
my Stock's not super high right now but
um if we're doing this movie we have to
shoot on film and the last thing I'll
say about it is I actually think um I
don't think it's much more expensive to
shoot on film as long as you're not
making a movie for 50 Grand or 100 Grand
but if you have if it's a low budget
movie that still has somewhat of a
budget
um I believe that I have to shoot very
efficiently so my shooting ratio is is I
think much more efficient than if I was
just shooting and shooting and shooting
there's a lot of planning that has to go
in ahead of time and I think even though
there's one light item or two line items
there's a scanning in the film that adds
some money to the budget I think we save
in so many other line items in post
because what we shoot is I mean when we
went into color uh we were just all we
were doing was leveling things out and
dialing them in but we weren't creating
a look at all in color in post so we
really saved a lot of money because we
were shooting film again I like to stay
open-minded with all the options out
there but the correct choice for this
movie everything comes together so well
so many more questions I love a lot of
movies that are shot digitally by the
way I mean I have the Nicholas winding
refin as well oh yes I I I just I think
film uh I think any movie that's that's
uh I think any movie would be just a
tiny bit better if it were shot on film
that's just my opinion I love it when
you're moving when your movie comes out
and everyone can see it we can go back
to all these questions that have like
question marks next to them because I
wasn't sure if it was crossing the line
into spoiler territory or not thank you
for that I must let you go though so you
can continue celebrating your movie at
Fantastic Fest congratulations on
strange darling thank you so much for
the for the compliments about the movie
I'm so glad you liked it I mean it cool